الذي يعرف
بالمنتقم دخل فعليا الخدمه في الجيش
الاوكراني قائد القوات الاوكرانيه
المشتركه وصف المنظومه بالجيده والفعاله
مضيفا ان الجنود العاملين على منظومات
افنجرز تدربوا على استخدامها في المانيا
السؤال ما هو هذا النظام اي افنجرز هو
نظام دفاعي جوي قصير المدى كما نتابع هنا
يملك ميزه اطلاق الصواريخ اثناء الحركه
ويعد عدو المروحيات الاول انشئ بواسطه
شركه بوينج وشكل عنصرا محوريا في هيكله
الدفاع الجويه المتقدم اذ يستخدم بشكل
اساسي لصد الاهداف الجويه منخفضه الارتفاع
كالمروحيات مثلا والمسيرات اضافه طبعا
للصواريخ والمقاتلات النظام يتم حمله على
مركبات هامفي متعدده المهام ويحوي ايضا
ثمانيه ص
موجهه بالاشعه تحت الحمراء يبلغ مدى
الصواريخ ما يقارب ثمانيه كيلو مترات كما
نتابع هنا تصل سرعتها الى نحو تسعه الاف
كيلو متر بالساعه هذه المنظومه تشمل كذلك
رشاشات ثقيله من عيار 12.7 مليمتر لزياده
كثافه النيران ونظاما الكترونيا للتحكم عن
بعد نظام افنجرز يتميز برادار امريكي
ثلاثي الابعاد متخصص بكشف الاهداف الجويه
على ارتفاعات المنخفضه ومتوسطه ويبلغ مداه
76 كيلو مترا بالاضافه الى ما سبق المنتقم
نظاما الكترونيا مضادا للتشويش ونظام
حمايه مضاده للصواريخ واخر لتعريف العدو
والصديق